hello everyone this is amin here from
audio science review today i have a
presentation for you on some research uh
about
how professional and proper evaluation
of speakers done
um in the industry and for research
motivations come from a number of videos
and blog posts
by traditional
magazine reviewers and the like
each one trying to defend their
turf and the turf being that the classic
reviewer of speakers and to some extent
uh headphones
wants to defend this what they call
subjective reviewing which is get a pair
of speakers set them up in their rooms
listen to it and give you the impression
and many are defending that saying this
is the right thing to do and they're
actually going a step further saying
that if you're aware of measurements
when you
evaluate the speaker you're actually
less scientific that what they're doing
by implication by not looking at
measurements or you know conveniently
not caring about measurements that
somehow they have uh they're speaking
more of the truth about
the performance of speaker
and uh
one of the things about those videos and
blog posts is that they usually are
devoid of any research or any anything
to back what their point of view is
they're just appealing to your gut and
what i just said probably makes sense to
you reviewer we'll go get a
speaker turn them on listen to them give
you impression
and uh why is their opinion correct well
because they've been doing this for
years and years and that
they're more of an expert in than
you and i are because they've been doing
that work and therefore they can give
you a
more correct opinion
i wanted
to dig into that but unlike their
approach i want to actually show you the
research and explain how
we go about this field how do you
evaluate speakers and
it's a topic that i don't think people
are familiar with at high level you
probably have heard some of the
buzzwords like blind testing and control
testing but i don't think the details
are known so hopefully we get
some good insight into how the research
approaches this topic and then i'll
bring it down to her to you know topic
at hand which is
um you know our reviews of speakers
trustworthy and
what is the proper way to approach this
what i call difficult topic
so let's get right into it
let me start at the beginning when i
decided to get into speaker testing and
reviewing about two years ago about the
equipment near-field scanner i was
actually quite concerned
it's one thing to have an electronic
product and we measure it and the
measurements are very very powerful and
conclusive and they're done
electronically so they're very high
accuracy far better than our ears it's
completely another to you know have
judgment on the speaker um
i'll explain a little bit later that we
do have powerful tools as far as
measurements that help with loudspeaker
evaluation but ultimately you know this
big responsibility was on my shoulder of
if i got into this how would i rank
speakers how would i rate them how would
i be able to defend that and
i
i didn't have a great idea beyond the
good measurements at that time and and
uh stumbled on a process of of getting a
good idea and i'll talk about that in my
approach at the end of this presentation
but before i do let me just say that it
is a hard thing um i don't think anybody
in the world with all the research
behind you could
100 percent prove that this is the best
speaker or is this the third best
speaker um
it's a tough tough things now what makes
it tough is that there is no reference
right now you're listening to me on
whatever headphone or speakers you're
listening to
do you think it sounds like me
you don't know right
even i don't know that sounds like me
because what i hear is not the same as
what the microphone is recording
um nothing is conveyed in this recording
to you as to how my voice is sounding
right now in this room that if you were
here and then you went and listened to
the recording they would sound identical
right and by definition this is a broken
architecture the delivery system can
have one tonality which the talent and
the producer and the label approve in
case of music in case of movies that you
know the director and what have you
they approve the sound in a specific
listening environment a professional
listening environment usually and then
they hand you this recording and then
you listen to it and we all aspire for
this high fidelity goal of hifi
yet we have no reference and if you
don't have a reference how do you know
something is is correct um if i have
this shade of red in here
how do you know this is correct red
likely this red won't look the same as
it's looking to me on my professional
monitor if you just have a consumer
device that read maybe a completely
different shape
uh different uh tonality um
but let's talk about that in both
photography and and video where this
problem was nailed and solved and
defined day one as part of the
architecture so what i have in here is
called the simple color bars
that's society of motion pictures and
television engineers they set a standard
and this just a set of colors so if you
take this and you put it in a recording
device and you capture that
and you calibrate the recording system
to be correct each one of these colors
has a specific measured value
and then
you give that recording to somebody and
they also calibrate their television or
display device to the exact same color
values again we're using a measurement
then the two shades of red are going to
be as good as the measurements will tell
you they are and if they tell you that
they're you know accurate within you
know 0.1 digit that's what you have you
know your uh red is not going to look
orange all of a sudden
your dynamic range different shades of
gray for example that can be calibrated
and so forth and in the old days this
was a huge problem today displays have
made massive progress even out of box
you know uh mass consumer devices do
well because partly because as people
measured it and people can can find out
if these things are accurate or not
likewise in photography we can have this
macbeth color chart and there are
different versions of this with with
different pictures
and
you can have this and you can take a
picture of it and then you can print it
and you can compare the print to the
real thing
and the two can be compared to get
accuracy so it's what are called end to
end calibration so you calibrate the
source to a specific standard and
calibrate the target to a specific
standard and then you're done so there's
no food fights we don't have the fights
that we have in audio and video because
you know displays either accurate or is
not accurate you know you can stop it
and measure a frame and still frame and
make measurements and yours if it's way
off his way off uh you know you can't
argue with that
now there are food fights in that world
also as well as the display technology
what have you but nowhere near what we
have in audio because we have that
reference in um audio we don't have that
in music we don't have that even sound
for video we don't have that
we have it for the video portion but we
don't have it for the
sound portion
to give you an extent of how bad the
problem is um general i guess top
three brands in the world as far as
professional monitors uh each monitor
that they produce they measure at the
factory and they have the measurements
actually they keep and then they send it
out to people to want to buy them to use
them for
professional applications so generally i
did a study of their customers uh this
is in uh
in the context of movies and they went
out and did measurements in here and
you can see the incredible variations
between the minimum and maximum
variations we have rooms in here there
are
minus 20 dv and then we have rooms here
they're plus 10 db so there's 30 db
variation
uh in here and base frequencies alone
excuse me um got a little bit better in
the mid bands but then it spreads out
again in in higher frequencies so
the music that you listen to the movie
soundtrack that you listen to may have
been mixed on any of these curves and
these are summary curves by the way not
the individual curves you know these are
means and averages and so forth but you
know each one may have landed somewhere
else and when they were mixing this
music or a movie soundtrack if their
bass was this hot they may have produced
it with less space or if their bass that
they were hearing was this low then they
were pulling it up to listen to uh worse
yet the in this for the movie industry
they use this one third octave
calibration from this old dolby standard
that's just badly broken and that one
third uh octave filtering is actually
smooth the heck out of these uh graphs
in reality you know it's actually a lot
worse than this so there is no truth in
production and you know that right you
listen to some music and it would be
bass heavy or will be too bright or it
could be anything right the attractor
track the tonality of of sound changes
so this creates a big problem for us
which is uh
you know if i want to objectively
analyze the sound of a speaker and uh
have you listened to it
you know and i play some music i mean
you know that's the that's the material
we want to know it sounds right i take a
track and i play it and speak tracy
chapman is one of the common research
tracks and so you listen to tracy
chapman and you listen to it on one
speaker uh now what what are you gonna
say oh has too much bass too much bass
relative to what but the vocals forward
forward relative to what how do you know
what tracy chapman's voice is like a and
how was it recorded maybe it was
recorded with too much bass or too
little bass and two little highs or too
much highs or was perfectly
normal how do you solve this problem
well until about 30 40 years ago it was
assumed that this was not a solvable
problem that every speaker is a shot in
the dark and oh by the way there was an
assumption made that all of us have
different tastes
and there was this art in a gray-haired
guy who sat there and designed the
speaker to
come up with a sound that people liked
all this changed when dr tool arrived at
national research council in canada
which is a research facility set up to
encourage different industries in canada
and audio was one of them and
he set out to find out if you know what
can we find out why people like certain
speakers more than the other
and he quickly realized that
you know the way you solve this puzzle
isn't by just listening to one speaker
and having somebody give a score to it
but that you compare two three or four
speakers against each other and an
interesting thing happens when you do
that when you compare three speakers
two of them
will have similar bass and then one of
them will have too much or too little
bass or too much of a little twitter
response or treble and
your brain at that point it becomes
calibrated wait a second these two
sounded right to me
and they're more common and this is the
one that's standing out
and the more of these you have when you
go to four that even gets better now you
have four alternatives so if two of them
by chance couldn't be both broken the
same way
and giving you that reference now
there's four so chances of you know
accidental matching with two broken
approaches uh gets much lower
excuse me and
that was the trick that solved this
problem so you listen to
a speaker b speaker c and speaker d and
you rate all four of them and only then
can you determine which one of these
speakers sounds better in what way which
one has better bass mid-range treble and
what have you because it's this
reference now
i'm telling you what the research is but
i can tell you also personal experience
i've been fortunate enough to go to
harmon twice
and
sat in their shuffler and control blind
test and i remember hearing the first
speaker ever in that test and it's all
blind there's a curtain you can't see
anything and the first speaker played
and they give you a score sheet one to
ten you're supposed to give a number and
there's no other instruction by the way
you decide what quality it means you
you're giving it one for horrible
speaker and 10 for ten you can imagine
any scenario you want in your head of
what is quality because of the life
uh whatever it's up to you
and i was like
okay is this a four is it a three is
there two is there a six is it ten but
you know what number do i give to the
speaker and i was totally lost until a
few seconds later speakers switched and
to a different speaker and all of a
sudden i said wow this this speaker
sounds so much better than the last one
let me go back and scratch the first one
and give it a much lower score because
now this is good and then the next
speaker by the way sounded very similar
to this and it actually was a tough
thing i was like i think i gave one a
six and a seven was very hard to decide
between those two but this the odd man
out was very easy to identify in
contrast well because i i heard c and b
and c and it was very clear and those
two immediately sort of
uh aligned with my mental view of what
sound should be but it took that sharp
comparison in situ in place um and a
switching time that was about four or
five seconds it takes for the speaker
shuffler uh pneumatic speaker shuffler
they have a harmon to switch speakers
and always then keeps the speaker listen
to in the right place
and that gets me to the second part of
this thing for this testing to work
speakers need the testing needs to be
blind and it needs to be randomized uh
randomized part i'll get to in a second
but it needs to be blind because when i
took this test the first one
first speaker was a plain
electrostatic speaker and the other one
was a horn speaker and the third one was
very attractive consumer speaker so i'll
tell you brands martin logan
jbl and bmw
if you look at those three speakers no
way can you put aside your mental
judgment of what speaker is that the
look and the design of those three
speakers i mean the bmw with his twitter
on top looks so iconic jbl has a horn so
if you don't like horns you immediately
say wow that's going to sound horny
and uh
let's excuse the term and the martin
logan you know with the electrostatic
panel and the supper from underneath
it's like you know depending on what
you're a fan of what good
impressions you've had in the past it
quickly colors your view of of that
world so
we want to not have that we want to just
judge the sound so
you know curtains put in front
acoustically transparent black
fabric is in front so you can't see the
speakers and now you have to judge it on
on that basis
the randomized part is that and i'll
talk more about this later on that we're
going to do a statistical analysis of
what are what is real data and what is
noise what's variability
and tons of uh fundamentals of statistic
relies on on samples to be random
if i want to do a drug study and uh i
only go pick females and not any males
well then suddenly representing females
and not males you want to have a
randomized study where randomized
selection of those where you have x mix
of you know males and females in there
if that's what you
try to represent the whole so you don't
want your sample to be
you know a specific sample you want to
be able to randomize this so when you
listen and you sit through the testing
um
the order of the speakers that you
listen to is randomized so they're not
one following the other one always that
can have a strong effect and you don't
know which speaker is playing when
and
different tracks are played and
different order of speakers is presented
to you another track plays different
order again and if another track is
played different order again so this
randomization is key it's not just you
know i always compare martin logan to
bmw in that sequence that screws up all
the statistical analysis and messes
things up um so right away we can tell
there's a problem with the typical
magazine reviewer says i'm doing things
scientifically because i don't look at
measurements like no you're looking at
the brand the
color the design the designer you
probably had you know two-hour
conversation or you knew the designer
you don't know the designer products
from china is from england or from us
from germany
all that stuff heavily influences the
impression people have of sound and
from that point of view it it really you
can't talk about the word scientific the
moment you look at these things and pass
judgment
now this one i've covered on the third
one it's very controversial with people
who haven't looked at the research but
the focus of everything i'm talking
about right now is on tonality tonality
by far sets the preference for a speaker
get the tonality wrong and control
testing and i don't care what else you
talk about you know distortion or
imaging and what have you they're all
distant second and third
naturally the speaker has to sound right
if it's too bright you know what do i
care about what the imaging is like or
how loud they can play it's too bright
so
research has shown that for us to
analyze the tonality of a speaker a
single speaker listened to in mono
configuration by far it gives you most
um
easiest situation for you to judge the
moment you make it stereo it drops like
a cliff where
the bad and a good speaker are judged
almost close to each other and by time
you go to 5.1 which is one of the
configuration tests essentially of the
crappy ones and and the gray ones sound
the same to most people uh ask bose you
know acoustic mass with the little
speakers 5.1 and subwoofer tons of
people will listen to that so it sounds
wonderful you know it sounds great you
know because
it's it's a surround and gives you that
impression so i have another dedicated
video on that i know a few people
disagree with that but just trust me
this is the way research is done for 40
years harman has a room that can do 5.1
shuffling of speakers they don't do it
not because they can't but because just
produces less accurate results and you
know as it is this job is hard why would
we want to make the job harder on
listeners let's make a job easier on
them listen to one speaker whatever
tonality it has is the same as having
two speakers generating the same
tonality so that's what we care about so
you gotta use single speaker when was
the last time you saw a subjective
reviewer listen to one speaker
never if you tell them that they think
it's sacrilegious why because they've
not just studied one paper on how proper
analysis of speaker tonalities done in
research for 40 years so they think you
have to listen to stereo and you have to
wax poetic about imaging and this and
that
no you want to tell me how the speaker
sounds you want to tell me the tonality
is correct you better use a single
speaker and you better do your testing
and mono by the way mono doesn't mean
that you mix the music to mono most
music these days at least the music i
listen to
is produced where
the two speakers mostly have the same
content so for my types of playlists i
just listen to one channel although i do
have a set of tracks that have converted
to mono it's a little tricky converting
things to monitor you may cause
cancellations or you may cause clipping
so as a practical matter you don't have
to go create mono tracks just listen to
a lot of uh you know as long as you're
using the same track
uh for every speaker you're evaluating
or everything you're doing it doesn't
matter there becomes a constant
okay now the last one is what makes it
hard for us to do it at this because the
speakers
um
should be in the same location should be
in the same situation the situation
meaning that at least you got level
matching and level matching is its own
kind of warrants
there are there's some work is done it's
not the strongest work as far as
research on how you match levels but as
a minimum you want to have a controlled
noise that you run and and with some
kind of weighting averaging um you match
levels so that they're within the
ballparks now i'd say it's not the most
solid thing because the frequency
response varies between different
speakers and so what are you matching
perfect matching can't be done but you
can get very close and close enough so
you've got to do that um but the same
location thing is very tricky if you
move a speaker in a room
the room modes get activated differently
and that changes the bass response and
the bass response is responsible for one
third of our preference on sound of a
speaker so
you've got to be very careful in
in not moving the speaker enough for the
bass response changes and therefore you
have apples and oranges now this can be
done but you have to then shuffle
speakers so if you have one speaker on
the right one speaker on the on the left
and you test them then you gotta have a
randomized version uh set of tests where
you
swap them and then test again and swap
them this again swap and test again and
that sort of randomizes the uh
the
location specific uh spectral changes uh
from the speaker and you can achieve the
same thing and indeed that's i think dr
tool did it originally
but there you know harman has a fortune
good fortune of having a speaker
shuffler so
this is the pioneering work that was
done dr tool in 1980s and it's continued
to this day and it's the gold standard
there is no other research type of that
i know into
preference testing of speaker that's
done any differently and again nothing
like that at what people do as far as
objectives
now
dr floyd toole sort of pioneered it but
pioneered this this game but his right
hand person's uh uh is uh dr sean olive
um and i've paced that as his old
qualification he's in the most qualified
person we have as far as practicing the
research in here and trying to get to
these
factors that influence our preferences
in loudspeakers he's published countless
papers by himself and together with
other researchers and he also came from
nrc and followed dr tulde harmon and you
know if you want to pause the video and
you can google this on on his background
online you're welcome to do so but you
know there's a name you want to know
and if a subjectivist reviewer has never
heard of uh uh dr oliver or dr floyd
toole then you sort of
you know guarantee that they know
nothing about the topic uh he's written
a lot of papers and done a lot of
research as i mentioned but i'm to focus
on one research paper
that this is the title and that's a link
if you want to go to it differences in
performance and preferences of trained
versus untrained listeners
harman has a simple tool you use to
train yourself and the training isn't to
like certain speakers sound or anything
like that it's a simple tool it's like
almost a video game where a track is
played and then
different regions of it equalized
you know tonality change and your job is
to identify
you know which one of the tonality
changes it is and the original initially
at lower levels
it makes broad changes and then it makes
the changes smaller small and smaller
and the requirement they have is that
you gotta reach level seven to be able
to be called a trained listener and in
addition these trained listeners not
only are trained formally in in this
kind of uh with this kind of tool and
examined and like passing a test and
certification but they also take many of
these tests so they're very familiar
in being able to probe and and focus on
the sound um
on this thing as opposed to you know
general pers uh you know random person
like when i was sitting there the first
time it's like okay what's what's this
setup you know they know the setup and
the exact so the question was and
they're marketing people pushing back on
on sean saying okay well
you know your uh
chain listeners may have different
preference than uh you know average
person or different reviewers or
different parts of the public you know
prove to us that that's not the case so
his goal in here wasn't as much to
determine you know what's the best
sounding speaker but also
if people from different walks of life
how do they do in these kinds of tests
do they prefer different speakers and
what is their performance in being able
to evaluate speakers
i'm going to warn you
that this paper is very dense uh typical
of journal papers that get published in
journal of audio engineering society
they gotta have weight to it
half the time tons of math in this case
is a huge amount of statistics
statistical
analysis and lingo and bunch of
references and they're usually quite
long so while normally encourage you to
go get these papers and read i don't
know if you're not a member i don't know
if i want to encourage you to go spend
33 to get this paper but know that this
is it is heavy stuff this is not some
casual conference paper which is the up
you know opposite of this or or another
way you can publish things at aes where
um you can write what you want and
normally they're not peer reviewed they
could be but they're they're not
normally peer reviewed so um this is a
you know substantial paper and this is
also
built on top of work that was done
similarly but older than this by
by
dr soren buck beck
sorry i was a researcher a professor and
also works at bangor olefsons
and one of our luminaries as well his
paper is also for statistics and uh so
these two sort of go together although i
don't think you need
dr beck's uh paper to fully understand
this one so my job in here is to walk
you through the parts of this thing that
that
are important and
you know and then just sort of tell you
that the you know the top lines in there
so what is the study um
different groups of people were brought
into harmon
and tested with the same set of uh two
sets of speakers and one case was three
speakers and the other case was four
speakers and each one of them will run
through the same process so imagine one
day they have their dealers from east
coast coming in
and
they have them sit through this course
and do the scoring and the data was
collected the next day or next week they
went and
got students from local university
and then one of the things they did
which we care a lot about here is that
they also went got some magazine
reviewers and they tested them and
that's the core area that i'm going to
focus on in here
and they also had 12 of their own
trained listeners um
you're welcome to read the rest of this
this abstract summary that's on the
website that you can get for free but
i'm going to dig into what these things
mean
but it's really comparison of these
different groups and how they did in the
research
one key thing they did in here which is
kind of clever and you don't normally
see it in these type of research papers
in that this test is uh testing multiple
factors simultaneously so we're not just
saying looking at okay these four
speakers which one sounds better that's
one factor the next thing we're also
looking at is different listener groups
and there were a huge number of
listening groups uh you know in this
thing i think there were 12 16 different
listener groups and it was across two
different tests and uh so
it's not you can slice and dice this
test in many different ways and you want
to step back and say all right
ultimately what was the biggest factor
that determined uh
you know the uh
that had an uh biggest
variable in all these things now ideally
we want the only thing to be a variable
is the speaker that
the
listeners were interchangeable with each
other right then that way it doesn't
matter who we use for listening tests
the results will be determining the
fidelity of the speaker
thankfully the loudspeaker
did achieve the highest and there's a
specific test that was done in here and
let you read that um in the paper if you
want but uh the analysis showed that the
loudspeaker was the number one
determinant or the most important factor
and the variable was was considered to
be large uh for loudspeaker but guess
what the next factor was was the
listening
group that was actually medium factor
and then which content that was used was
a mild factor
so unfortunately this means that you
pick the wrong listener group you may
actually wind up with different speaker
results because they have a you know
very large influence on assessment of
fidelity of speakers
if you step back you know when i use an
instrument measure speaker i have a
precise tool that
is very repeatable when i replace that
machine with a person i want that person
to be ideally as good as that
measurement instrument but if they have
this level of influence on on the test
result
that's not a good thing
now how do we determine um reliability
of uh
these uh
reviewers
as i said every one of these groups
listened to the speakers and they
generated a
large set of data as first the
scoring that they gave and uh in a
simpler
simplest sense of their layman means you
know you think okay i'll just take the
average of these things and they'll tell
me you know how good the uh um
the speaker is but there's a problem
with that in that there is a variability
in the opinions of of of these testers
in how they array the speaker um
you know when i as i mentioned the tests
are randomized so i listen to speaker a
when is played first and i give it
five as a score when it's randomized and
i don't know when it comes up again and
this time i give it a score of seven
then next time i give it six so there's
variability even for the same score now
you could get the mean for all these
things or the average uh on these things
and you may think okay a speaker that
has a mean of uh five
is uh worse sounding than the score than
the speaker that has a mean of six
that may make lay um
sense but it's actually not correct
because there can be a statistical error
in that uh sample that we have uh let's
say i picked totally on you know people
that don't know
what is a good speaker once a bad
speaker and they do this you know voting
i don't want to just take their value
you know their their mean or their
average and say let me run with it i
want to look at the variability in their
voting and based on that decide what is
the likelihood that what they're
how they're scoring the speakers is
actually correct and it's not due to
chance and due to variation
now there's an entire field of
statistics called the anova or analysis
of variances
each one of these groups in in here that
i have for you they all have variances
within
their scoring
and
you know i'm not going to try to teach
you the statistical concepts in here but
essentially you can take the variances
and
analyze them and decide whether the
variances are enough
to be a show stopper or that they're
telling the truth and usually we pick a
confidence interval in this case i'm
showing you a five percent confidence
interval which means we are 95
um
a chance of being correct in the
conclusions that we want to draw and the
conclusion you want to draw in this case
is that speaker a is better than speaker
b and worse than speaker d and these are
their scores
so as part of anova you you do a special
analysis called the f value which is a
ratio that you take which is a
difference between the means of
different groups and then
to the and you divide that by the
variances within your own group
and uh
the the more variances you have within
your group
the more you drag down this f value
and the lower the value
the higher probability of chance that
that makes the results
unreliable and if you look at the f this
ratio distribution is sort of front
loaded so if you got a two out of it you
know and that ratio for that f value for
that speaker rating you're way below the
confidence that we want to have in here
the farther you are the bigger the f
value the more you push to the right of
this curve and the more you push down to
the right of curve the less doubt we
have that you really really were able to
detect the differences between the
speakers and it wasn't something by
chance and it wasn't just randomness
that that
got you here uh was that that we have
high confidence in the results
so
uh sean olive took
these different
sets of reviewers that came in and and
bucketed the computer there have value
for every uh person that was in that
category and just simply took the the
mean or the average of them
and the uh their trained listeners got a
score of about 94.6
and for the purpose of marketing he
pushed that up to be 100 scaled at up to
100. so relative to them the next group
that did well was way worse and this is
their dealers the audio retailers and
you can see their reliability is way to
heck worth it was about 30 or so now
it's still statistically valid in in
that they were able to
there were differences in the
loudspeaker so we can use their scores
but the reliability was worse and who's
worse than them even
audio reviewers these are professional
audio reviewers and look at their score
in here they're around 20 so about five
to one ratio between these two groups as
far as the trained people and untrained
people
what does that mean in practice
excuse me in order to get
data from audio reviewers to be as good
as what we can get with trained
listeners we have to
use a lot more of them
and once we have a lot more of them then
the variance falls out of them
and and the data becomes more reliable
the fewer audio reviewers you have the
higher chances of randomness and not
being able distinguishing between
statistically distinguishing between
speakers so just imagine if this thing
shrinks down to one which is single
review writing in a magazine what are
the odds of that being statistically
valid in their opinion so it would be
way down here it will be completely
useless uh on this thing so this is a
power of training and you know it's this
is the data that's just extensively
analyzed so this is not just some you
know what thumb in the air saying hey
i've been doing this for 25 years so i
know what i'm doing
and uh and that's what i just explained
that the uh the trained people again all
they were trained on is to just know the
tonality of speakers you know that's too
much bass or too much mid-range and what
band that's all the training was for the
trained people and some experience
taking these stats that's five times
better than reviewers and 27 times
better than students but the problem
with students was that they liked
everything so
which is you know something that we can
appreciate that you know to them a big
nice high five system just sounds good
and uh this is a damning statement and
that these reviewers are actually worse
than dealers and the sales people
in a showroom that you go and most of us
you know scuffed listening to a salesman
at the audio retailer telling us what
sounds good what doesn't and yet these
people did even worse than that um
why it's hard to know maybe you know
they have more opportunity to get
trained and they have more opportunity
to play with equipment and in more
control setting i don't know but um
certainly this is this does not bode
well for uh maximum reviewers pumping
their chest and saying hey i know what
i'm doing
now
you know we get back to this common myth
that we all
like we all have different tastes
we do not
remember there some 256 people were
tested in this study
across many different walks of life and
you can see all these different labels
that harmon's given to them as far as
which group they were in the academia
and then we have the reviewers here
circled um this is the harmon one and
there are other ones in here that i'm
not going to get into the dealers for
example and so forth but look at the way
they scored the speakers in here look at
the speaker in green um speaker
look at the scores that the uh
that it got was the worst one
across any group so whether it was
students or whether it was reviewers or
whether it was harman people they were
trained all of them gave speaker ram the
worst uh rating in controlled blind
tests
um so the preference of all of these
people was the same now what did the
train listeners do gave it horrible
scores right they said this is a
terrible terrible speaker so they're
trained people
have less tolerance for bad sound they
immediately spot it and they give it you
know close zero score in here with
almost no variance on on this thing
um the next speaker was this b speaker
again
you know you can see that there are
variables between who tested it but as
far as ranking is the next good speaker
right it's the one that's above m
speaker but depend no matter who took it
the score is always above green and it's
always below these last two speakers
speaking of the last two speakers the p
and i more or less a statistical tie the
trained listeners could not tell them
apart they give them similar preference
ratings and the other two groups more or
less you know has a lot of variation in
there and but
the two of them together took the third
place so first second and third
if this if it were true that we all have
different tastes this thing should have
been jumbled up mess right that if you
know this thing you know like the green
one you know maybe if a train listens
with zero but for uh let's say reviewers
would give it number one and it would
have been way up here but it's not it's
all orderly stacked charged in the grand
scheme of things you gotta let your eyes
filter these things because again there
are variances in here you can see the
error bars in there it's not a precise
thing in in statistics
okay so please please accept this now is
it possible that one
out of 100 likes different things yes
there are people who hate the taste of
chicken or they won't eat fish but
most of us
like chocolate ice cream like a steak
like similar things and that makes sense
that the same thing applies to speakers
otherwise a crazy world out there where
the anything goes
the most important part and this is
repeated in so many studies uh they're
published by harman and nrc and dr uh
floyd tool and and dr allu is this
correlation between measurements and
speakers and this is a fascinating
assessment it's a it is from a
presentation by the way different than
the study that i was just showing you
um
if you look at these two speakers you
can see one that's very very well
behaved this loudspeaker too look at the
frequency response quite smooth not
perfect but quite smooth and look at
this other speaker very very jagged
response with with twitter response much
hotter than the rest of it
they
harmon took these train listeners and
had them rate this on specific bands i
think they were six bands uh of of
tonality and had them rate you know is
the tonality neutral that would get a
zero and if the tonality was bad or you
know it would get a score down and up
and look at what happened when they did
that for this speaker look at the line
that they produce is almost the same as
their frequency response so that their
the
train listener was able to work as a
crude spectrum analyzer and correctly
identified the tonality of the speaker
as being essentially doesn't have enough
bass which we know it doesn't you know
need a subwoofer to get that zero you
know down to 20 hertz but above 80 90
hertz they essentially say it's good and
then look at this speaker it also
doesn't have bass but the you know the
response from here to here and lower
mid-range also terrible and then look at
this they also uh produced you know they
correctly guessed that the speaker's too
bright
so this tells us that a training works
but b we can also use measurements
instead of people because they speak the
same language in here
so
if you look at it they
tested this across 13 speakers and this
is the mean as far as the correlation
between listening test results and
and the
measurements and it's 95
that's incredibly good
so
this points to a training is very good
but b also measurements are very good in
in trying to
uh predict what the human ear will hear
uh correct measurements
so what's a summary so far and apologize
for the getting long but
it's got to be a long presentation but
we're getting closer to the end um
just like any other profession training
works
um you know you don't become an athlete
because you keep reading books about you
know how fast you can run you run and
you have a coach that teaches you that
you know maybe there's a you know you
compete and against others and so forth
so it's no wonder that there's a
professional process to get trained and
if you haven't been through that
then you're not trained
the years of experience thing the chest
pumping thing i've been doing this for
30 years must be doing something right
no that doesn't mean anything because we
just tested you when we know the results
where we have a superior group to you
evaluating an identical speaker an
identical situation and their variation
in scoring is like this and your
variation scoring is way to heck out
here when you listen to the same speaker
it comes around second or third time
you're not able to rate it the same way
with the same you know closing values
which means you're all over the map so
your 20 30 40 years of experience didn't
do you a lot of good yeah you're better
than maybe general public but not nearly
as much as you think
so
um
from my point of view then this
basically writes off listening to a
single reviewer giving me an opinion
about a speaker there's nothing they're
doing right at all whatsoever they're
not in control situation they're not
listening to mono it's not done blind
and they're not trained and they're just
one of them
you know a lot of them they brag well so
and so a bunch of people kind of agree
with me yeah
fortune tellers can reach a fortune too
and make you think you know that they
can read your fortune but we all know
they can't
so you know that chance agreement
especially if you write vague things in
in english
as the typical reviewer is uh yeah you
can get people to agree with you but
it's not right
but importantly
measurements are really really really
powerful the good ones the good
measurements and we'll get into that
so i've been talking about this but let
me just bring you you know if you don't
want to listen to me and listen to the
kind of pioneered this um there's a
video here with aaron with dr floyd two
and around uh 15 minutes or so 14 and a
half 15 minutes
um the discussion dr tools is this the
uh
explaining this notion of you need more
than one speaker to listen to to be able
to make a judgment and uh you know it
comes out and deserve exact codes says
comparative listening is critical to
forming
accurate subjective impressions that
means comparing
more than one speaker against each other
not just listen to one and he just comes
out and says look and if you're
listening to just one speaker it
essentially almost means nothing it goes
on to say maybe you can say what tune it
was
in this thing on this thing but it
really doesn't tell you anything
accurate so the notion that hey i'm
going to go you know set up speakers
from my home and i can give you unbiased
opinion about the thing it's like no you
give me garbage opinion that's what
research tells us for 40 years if we
could do it the way reviewers do we
would do it in research what's easier
than bringing a person sitting in front
of a stereo speakers and say what do you
think score one to ten oh okay next
person next person why run through these
randomized control tests and blind and
everything if we didn't need to do that
we do them because we have to painting a
negative four-way comparison speakers
versus one if i want to compare one
speaker that i don't have to shuffle
anything but we have to it's just the
nature of the thing the worst one is
this take home version um
i do this all the time you know i listen
to a uh i take a headphone i measure it
and i equalize it
and i still have certain experience then
i leave it on for a few hours i'm
listening then i turn off the eq
it's amazing how my ears had adapted to
that as being the new normal and then
you hear this impressive change
at that time that's much larger than if
you were doing it at the beginning of
the session
because your ears adapt to these things
and indeed even the worst speakers
you'll adapt and if they're too bright
that becomes your new references your
new normal
use a common phrase now and
the longer you use a speaker the worst
your impression of that speaker is as a
reviewer so don't tell me that you took
this home and you spent a week and two
weeks three weeks oh man i really work
on these reviews i listen to thousands
of tracks and everything and then then
after three weeks tell you what it's
like emir tests the speaker in one day
and it comes down to what it sounds like
it can't possibly be correct like no
you want you to not have adaptation
we're in our brain designed to adapt you
live in your home you adapt those
acoustics all the time otherwise you'd
be bothered like heck
as you move around in different parts of
your your room your brain is learned to
adapt to adapt your environment and it
just filters out consistent coloration
to some extent so if it's always bright
it says okay that's always bright it's
not new information i'm not going to
keep recapturing that as as
usual thing so don't believe me queue up
this video go to minute 15 listen to it
i'd encourage you to listen to the whole
thing um disappointed that aaron asked
him this question and then he's still
advocates listening to speakers in his
home and before the measurements and
he's proud of the fact that he doesn't
look at measurements therefore they must
be more scientific as a single person
tester uh aaron's a good guy but i'm
just telling you there's nothing
scientific about a sided test of putting
two speakers in a room
and listen to it i don't give you that
impression but actually i do i give you
a mere version of okay or not okay but i
wouldn't in a
million years try to prove to you that
that's that's a correct assessment
because it isn't you have to do a
multi-way
test
and if you're not doing this multi-way
test you're not randomizing it you're
not controlling the volumes and so forth
you're really generating garbage it's
not a reliable assessment
so where do we go so if listening tests
are painted like they're difficult and
actually impossible to do at home what
should a reviewer do
by golly start with measurements because
i just explained four years of research
says
the correct measurements these
spinoramas that we i show you at the
audio science review
these are highly predictive of our
preferences and the number one thing i
look at and research tells you is that
you look at on axis the direct sound
comes to your ear what is this tonality
if it's all chewed up it's not correct
it's not good i don't care if you
associate more highs as being more
detailed and all that stuff it's just
not correct it'll wear on you it's just
not the way the music was produced it's
not a high fidelity experience so you
want that to be a smoothie gun and if
you get a speaker that has that you
ignore everything else about it you're
60 percent there 70 percent there in
weeding out whole bunch of crappy
speakers because the tons of speakers
are below that can't achieve that and
the second thing is extremely important
is the off-axis sound which is the sound
that hits the walls and reflects comes
to you and the strongest ones of those
reflections and we want that to have
similar tonality to the on axis pick
those two
to be correct in the speaker that you
buy and you're 80 of the way they are if
not 90 to 100 percent you basically
weeded out tons of tons of bad designs
and bad speakers out there and that
should be your goal that should be what
you want to get out of a review
you interested in the speaker i'm
reviewing it or somebody else reviewing
it the measurements will get throw out
80 90 percent of the unknown about the
sound of a speaker for you hugely
increasing your odds that if you go by
that speaker you're gonna like it
because these two factors weed out this
stuff now
we're anal about this thing
i don't want to stop at 89
and i want to get to 90 95 if i'm gonna
say some speakers good let's let's cover
some other holes in the measurements
the number one hole we have which
research just doesn't address is this
dynamic playback capability
all the research uses a standard for
loudness and they said all speakers to
that loudness it's medium level loudness
when i've taken the test and
certainly not as loud as i like to turn
off the volume and take powered monitors
some of them can have incredibly good
objective frequency response
measurements but you turn up the volume
and the internal amplifier limits and
starts to crackle or the driver's too
small and bottoms out and it crackles
i don't need measurements for that
i'm listening to it all sudden i hear
crackle
i i you know it doesn't you know i could
show you a thousand distortion charts
and i wouldn't be able to show you at
the point where the thing is crackling
but my ears instantly tell me i don't
need a blind test i don't need control
tests i don't need anything it crackles
you doubt me cuts it next to me i'll
turn it on it'll crackle when it
crackles it's either loud enough or this
isn't loud enough ah that's subjective
when i tell you that i like it loud and
it's good as a reviewer i set it up set
the bar high by the way i don't listen
to loud music all the time or even
much vast majority of time but
occasionally i want to have be able to
turn up the volume and i want that to
scale up linearly not to bottom out it's
like a car you want to accelerate and
pass another car you don't want the car
all sudden to tell you no no i don't
have enough power i'm sorry you're on
your own now it's like no i want to
accelerate and pass somebody i want to
do whatever speed and acceleration i
want to have same speakers so i hold a
very high standards for dynamic
capability that doesn't mean that i'll
take a three-inch speaker expected to
get super loud but i expect everything
to at least reach a level of competence
and the higher end the speaker is the
better baby in that so that one is an
easy low hanging fruit and i'm saddened
that no reviewer does this i mean read
the typical subjective reviewer when
does he tell you how loud he could play
it and how did it get distorted i have
specific tracks of music i use that has
deep bass and a sub bass in it that just
instantly brings the speaker to his
knees if it's not tuned right and
doesn't have enough power it's got sub
bass response from
20 to 30 hertz and by the way i have ton
of tracks that spectrum 2030 here's i
don't know where this myth comes from
that it's not common there's tons and
tons of music out there maybe in the old
days that you bought records or you
listen to you know 20 tracks at home you
didn't have it but now with you know
music subscription it's so easy to just
cycle through so much music and as i
listen to it i have a spectrum analyzer
on my army adi 2 deck and i i hear it
and i you know listen to the headphones
usually and see the spectrum shooting up
you know in the first second bars in
this thing and i collect these tracks
and
it's just child's play playing boom low
volume is okay and by the way some of
them don't reproduce it
which could be plus or minus and i'll
note that
now that's the easy part again people
don't do it but that's the easy part the
second one is harder which is i have a
frequency response and uh it's not
perfect this is a genelec 83 38 that i
just tested recently and it's extremely
good speaker compared to many but it's
got this little bit of a peaking that
comes up here during the crossover
region
and tiny bit over here and how
significant is that
now people who advocate all measurements
will have trouble with this what is the
response of this thing i mean i could
guess and say oh you know 2 000 to three
thousand hertz a little bit more energy
and by the way some people cheat and
write reviews that way they claim to not
have looked at the measurements but
they're very specific about where the
problem is two thousand three three
thousand like yeah right you know you
didn't look at measurements of course
you look at the badge of it there's no
way you're that accurate
in knowing where the problem areas are
um but you know i'm transparent with you
and i say yeah this probably is audible
it's 3 4 db over here but it's kind of
chewed up and variation it's not like
it's a steps up and slips down
you know our hearing resolution of our
hearing um the bandwidth of auditory
filters widens so in a sense it's
filtering averaging these peaks and
troughs and maybe it's averaging this
with this and we don't know
so what i do is that uh
i come up with a process that has just
worked so beautifully and been doing it
you know since i started which is
i'll take this frequency response and go
develop a parametric eq and i do the
inverse of this so in this case i
designed a filter and i you know i was
quick and dirty doesn't have to be
precise i designed a filter i took this
entire range and just dropped the 340 db
and once i did that
in my roon player where i have this
parametric eq i can just i just turn
that filter on and off instantly on off
on off on off
and uh
i can do that instantly whereas when i
was listening to harm the harmon the
speaker shuffle takes four or five
seconds that's like a long time compared
to this this is very fast and the
fastest switching time is the more your
short-term memory is active and the
better judgments you can make so i'm
able to check very small variations in
in frequency response and do it quickly
and sometimes i say okay this sounds
better but boy the difference is very
small let me do it blind i close my eye
and i click the mouse enough time where
the thing gets randomized and then
i then evaluates a b a b a b which one's
better then i open my eyes look at it
and by the way i can do it for other
people i've had my son
money's here he listens uh usually his
headphone testing where i do this with
him listen to the headphone and
a b testing the equalization or one band
or more bands and say all right you know
what's your preference don't tell him
anything about anything he can also turn
away not even look at it i've done it
blind on him where i do a and b and a
and b and so okay which one you like
better and you get a fully objective
control test
i do volume adjustments sometimes
necessary by the way controlling volume
so everything that the
standard requires i'm able to do for
free
instantly i can do this now
one of the cool things about this is
that is this
well let me i'll come back to the second
this kind of method of using
equalization is a huge part of dr shawn
allen's headphone research early on he
realized that if you take a headphone
and you want to do a b test people can
tell from the feel of the headphone um
which one they're listening to and that
was a dead giveaway so the person says
oh this is the one with the big pads so
i'm going to give it a score of this so
instead of doing that they took a
surrogate headphone they took one
headphone and measured this frequency
response then they measure the frequency
response of all the other headphones
they wanted to test and electronically
activate them on top of this so they did
the difference between them and
make this chameleon headphones sound
like the other ones they also tested the
eq version of this headphone against the
real one and they found about 85
correlation between the two so good
enough for this kind of research and an
amazing you take the identical headphone
depending on how you eq it you can score
of zero bottom of the barrel to a score
of 10 on top
and all you've done is change the
tonality so
using equalization is absolutely correct
and scientific way to make evaluations
now hasn't been applied to speakers like
i'm doing it but i think it's it's the
very very very powerful thing
i've tested about 166 speakers not over
25 years over two years so i get to
practice this day in day out every two
three days i'm either testing a
headphone or i'm doing a speaker and i'm
telling you this this process of
developing equalization and doing a b
testing is exceptionally powerful
exceptionally solid way of evaluating
frequency response errors and if you
find frequency response errors that can
be correct with the eq guess what you
have you have a nice
um eq model now to make the speaker more
perfect i can make speakers jump one two
or three points in scale one to ten with
just equalization i've taken a clip
speaker that was so bright but had good
directivity meaning on and off axis work
the same and brought it down to make it
a very accurate speaker and with zero
cost didn't have to go mess with the
crossover there's this guy gi research
danny goes in there and rips about this
speaker and puts all new crossover in
there why unless there's a specific
issue that crossover
can fix if it's just tonality i can do
things he can't dream about doing inside
a crossover i can take any frequency any
with any shape and make a correction try
to do that with an eq with inductors and
resistors and capacitors every one of
those bands will you have to put a bunch
of filter network in there and have poor
accuracy and variation
use equalization equalization's
absolutely absolutely powerful
so we get into the end one-hour
presentation
so start from the top
if you're doing a one-off review of a
speaker i'm sorry but there's just
nothing about your assessment of the
sound of the speaker it's scientific
reliable or something you can rely on
you know appeal to lay intuition that's
you know review speakers for so many
years it really means nothing it just
that's the nature of the game now
subjective review talking about the
design of the speaker
look of it and
history of it because of it all that is
valuable information that i wish they
would just focus on that
not screw around would try to tell us
you know how the world turns and by the
way the moment they start using
different pieces of music and every
speaker that's also when you give up i
use the exact same tracks all the time
because your ears get trained you know
you know what the tonality of that track
should be and
not this thing of it becomes a music
discovery you want to tell me about her
music write an article about that
if you're a professional reviewer
magazine and you want to do right lead
with the measurements don't make it a
little footnote at the end push it down
to little
section of it um
on this thing it's just a shame how far
either the measurements have been raised
out of these professional reviews or
they've been relegated to afterwards you
know here's the measurement and the poor
measurement guy gets the results and
then he has to make sense of you know
how the subjective reviewer put his foot
in his mouth and a lot of times they
have to be politically correct so it's
just tough it should be the other way
around just like i do in my reviews
measurements are first let's analyze
that let's see what it tells us then we
get into a subjective listening we
verify what we've done in measurements
determine the impact of things that we
we have in the measurements and cover
things that we don't do like you know
listening to the uh
dynamic capabilities and so forth
uh on this thing and the key to all this
thing is equalization equalization i
can't tell you what a miracle this is in
this context in a larger context which
i'll cover later on so
this method is working for me
i can defend my results there's a
foundation to everything i'm doing as
you've seen i'm showing you research i'm
sharing backup it isn't just gut feeling
that hey if i just listen to these
speakers and i can tell you the sound or
you know not looking at the measurements
the good things like no by definition
everything i do relies on measurements
my job is to make measurements more
accurate through listening tests it
isn't to have a completely different
universe for measurements versus
uh listening tests no the listen the
measurements are so good and so accurate
we just want to add a layer on top and
and complete them we're not trying to
present you with an entire different
universe that's based on zero signs and
say hey now it's up to you to deal with
the conflict in here it's like no you
give me junk science over here i'm not
going to listen to that it's just
nonsense it's entertainment you know i
watch those subjective reviews many of
them do a great job they're nice you
know well-liked people it's
entertainment and it's informational you
know what the speaker is who makes it
what have you those are all good
information to have but telling me that
you know
this track you listen to and these you
know the guitar and these other
instruments should be more separate than
they are and if it's just a folklore
it's just not worth
dealing with
so that's where i am with this thing
uh hopefully you see the logic in it
hopefully you won't ask again do you
look at the measurements or not by the
way when i first turn on the speakers or
headphones i'm not looking at any
measurements at all i just listened just
like you would maybe i have a vague idea
of my head but i don't go memorizing
those graphs either i listen and i do
form an opinion very quickly but i am
not going to publish that opinion to you
i'll go develop it then i'll look at the
measurements i applaud equalization and
in case of that genelec speaker i
decided the eq wasn't doing much there
was a toss-up and i said you don't even
need to eq
but if you like you can you have the
data you can judge whether you have to
do it or not okay thanks for watching
this very long video hopefully you got
something out of it uh apologize for the
length of it i don't know how to make
this topic any shorter than this and
cover all this material even if you
don't care about this whole reviewer bit
hopefully you understand how proper
listening tests are done and what is the
right way to
assess the performance of a speaker
okay see you in a future video hopefully
a much shorter one thanks for watching
bye